Chris Mannix the intrepid Sports
Illustrated senior NBA writers most
recent column NBA must not let the
seasons return distract from black lives
matter movement and Chris joins us now
from Boston how did this start Chris
that you had some of these players
bringing up their concerns about if we
play basketball takes away from what is
going on this social platform that they
have right now well Dan Kyrie Irving was
the driving force behind this recent
call and his message to the 80-plus
players that were on this call was that
you know there should be some
consideration put in to the fact that
once we go down there and start playing
again the narrative shifts entirely and
look he's not wrong
I mean when players show up in Orlando
media that's been clamoring to you know
get a piece of them for the better part
of the last few months will start
writing about LeBron James as chase for
a championship and Ben Simmons returned
to Philadelphia and you know what can
what is the status of Kawhi Leonard and
Paul George with the Clippers and you
know they're they're our players you
know Irving the most vocal among them
that believed this is a time in this
country's history a movement where that
kind of distraction just simply
shouldn't take place so that was the
impetus behind that phone call to let
players speak out on issues like this as
they try to make a decision okay
but in the end ultimately it feels like
it's LeBron Jameses decision here even
Patrick Beverley who doesn't get along
with LeBron tweeted out LeBron wants to
hoop we're hoping here is their I don't
I just don't know Kyrie Irving's plan
Chris if he has a detailed plan of if we
don't play basketball then what do we do
and can you do both in your bubble in
Orlando no look LeBron's position which
has been an ongoing position for him
dating back to 2017 I wrote about the
time when Donald Trump was going after
the NFL players for kneeling LeBron said
specifically my voice is stronger than
my knee and he's always held that
position that if he's out there in the
fourth
he can do more good than it beats if he
you know boycott something or or take
small more divisive stand so I think a
lot of players will follow suit I think
Kyrie Irving's only plan and his push to
players was look just don't show up and
you send a pretty strong message about
the strength of this movement
don't be parts of the ultimate
distraction I mean look I have a hard
time Dan as a white man kind of
quibbling with Kyrie on this I've never
walked a mile in his shoes I've never
experienced some of the things that he's
experienced so if he feels this strongly
that not showing up sends a stronger
message than showing up it's fine to
have a difference of opinion with LeBron
it's just the way Kyrie and I can tell
you a number of other players feel yeah
I agree with you I said this from the
outset sometimes we'll shoot the
messenger and not listen to the message
and I think Kyrie can be polarizing and
I want to listen to the message and I'm
right there with you I don't know what
he's experienced I just want to know if
there is no basketball is there a plan
or is that the statement they're going
to make this is so important we are
going to forego an NBA season plus Kyrie
not playing that probably may draw you
know a little bit of a well wait a
minute here if he was playing and LeBron
wasn't playing would you know he'd be
saying the same thing and maybe that's
not fair but but the fact that he's not
going to be playing and LeBron has a
chance at another championship they
worked hard all season to get the number
one seed you know all of these things so
I don't know you kind of throw it into
the the pot here and I'm not sure what
the Commissioner thinks about all of
this and and how does he troubleshoot
this well to your point Dan from a
public perception standpoint there
really could not have been a worse
messenger than Kyrie Irving you know
because of the fact that he's not
playing and he spent the better part of
the last two years viewed as one of the
more divisive forces in the NBA with the
locker room and everything happened in
Boston and his subsequent move over to
Brooklyn all that being said there's
going to be a season like the NBA is not
even remotely considering the
possibility of not coming back there's
just not a belief and I think this
belief
this feeling is strong enough that
there's not bleep is not gonna be enough
players that decide not to go there'll
be a few players maybe even more than a
few players that decide not to go but
not enough that would deter the NBA or
the Union for that matter which has been
in lockstep with the NBA throughout this
process from not bringing the game back
the question is in the next couple of
days and weeks
what kind of statements will the NBA
said what kind of actions will they take
to try to convince the players that are
on the fence about this that coming back
is the right thing will it be some form
of donation or a commitment to do
something while you're in Orlando that
will keep the spotlight on this social
justice movement I think that's
something I know that some of the NBA is
discussing actively and will probably
have something to reveal in the coming
days and weeks we're talking to Chris
Mannix of Sports Illustrated senior NBA
writer I was also wondering you have
Dwight Howard and Avery Bradley on the
same team as LeBron James this this
isn't cause for concern at this point no
if we get to a different point maybe
look Dwight Howard's agents already come
out and said like he hasn't made a
decision yet
Dwight have that statement but then his
agent kind of countered it and I don't
think Avery Bradley's made any strong
decisions yet either I think knowing
Avery Bradley a little bit I think Avery
just wants to see something come from
the NBA like I was talking about some
sort of plan to keep the pressure on or
keep the spotlight on this particular
issue but Dan it's important to know to
the players are not speaking with one
voice on all this I mean there are
myriad issues out there that players are
kind of sifting through at this moment I
mean health concerns continue to be real
I mean the NBA is talking about a bubble
but the fact that Disney employees might
be able to come and go as they please I
mean it makes it more of a spaghetti
strainer than it is an actual bubble I
mean you've got players that are going
to be quarantined in there but others
that are staff workers might be coming
in and out I mean I don't care how much
personal protective gear you're wearing
or how much distance you keeping from
players you're still running a risk that
you can cause and fetch so that's a
concern and let's be reeled in for a lot
of players some mostly the guys in their
20s there are lifestyle issues here like
not a lot of guys are eager to go
quarantine down Orlando
for several months especially ones that
don't play golf and that might just feel
like they're just stuck in one place you
know doing nothing and I was wondering
about that just that the physical
condition could decide who wins this
championship because once you get there
in late July then it starts you don't
have much ramp up time I've seen
pictures of James Harden working out
looks like he's lost 15 pounds but
here's a guy who has asthma who's gonna
be going down into that bubble there I
don't know what LeBron has been doing or
the Greek freak has been doing but you
know that could that could go a long way
in deciding who's gonna win this
championship is just who's in the best
shape yeah it's interesting I was
talking to Brett Braun the Sixers coach
about this just yesterday and one of the
things that Brett said was as important
as physical shape is it's about kind of
your mental state as you go down to
Orlando and this is gonna be a
completely new situation we're at a bare
minimum you're probably gonna be there
30 40 days and if you're successful
significantly longer how mentally
steeled are you for this type of kind of
setup and also how much how well you get
along with your teammates like I mean
how you're gonna be in proximity with
these guys for a significant amount of
time like do you have the kind of
camaraderie that you probably need to
have to survive I mean these things
least to a coach like Brent Brown I'm
sure others these things are just
important as the physical issues that
stove behind you be honest how many
times have you used that in the last
year do we include pasta all right don't
let you sneak that in if I got rid of
pasta how many times have you used that
that stove oh I mean I think my old
softball gloves inside the actual stove
I mean if you look behind me at the
fridge if I open it up I'm pretty sure
they'd be I don't like 3/4 of a pound of
salami can you also know these I'm not
doing that there's no way okay so Bud
Light in there some Gatorade right I'm
into soapy water now so that's kind of
probably a bunch of that soft hey good
to talk to you I also saw what the
Players Association doesn't expect fans
at NBA
next season well a little bit too soon
to tell yeah that one I mean you know
it's one of the question that's gonna be
coming up Dan is we will the NBA keep
fans out of stands completely or they
look at states that are allowing things
to happen and say you can put fans in
stands I mean this is gonna be something
that comes up because owners of those
teams are gonna say like if you're Mark
Cuban in Dallas or you know in San
Antonio or the Rockets like where Texas
is start open up significant already are
you gonna say look you're gonna cost me
all that revenue when my state says I
can open up and have three-quarters of
capacity Florida which we've seen open
up already a couple of teams down there
this is going to be a challenge if there
are states like New York and California
that are still operating under
significant restrictions
how will the NBA I mean how will they
sort of thread that needle where they
have these owners that are able to make
money off fans and stands but they can't
do it because the rest of the league
can't that's that's a challenge believe
in it the NBA's talking about right now
good to talk to you Chris thanks as
always we appreciate your time
all right then